so this idea that if you tax them they'llleave
it is based on an intentional obfuscation
and confusion of wealthy people who
are ordinary people with high-paying
jobs and super super wealthy people with
hundreds of millions of pounds of assets
okay I want to do one on the
difference between wealth and income
uh we've covered this a bit on the channel before
but I think it's important to go over it once
again to answer some of the most common questions
we're getting recently which are basically No.1
people who are not super rich but have decent
jobs and are worried we're trying to tax them
and No.2 this question of if you tax the rich
they'll leave okay so first we need to just
cover very quickly the difference between wealth
and income uh income is basically about your job
your salary the money you get from working where
aswealth is about your accumulated assets uh
stocks & shares, property, land... people that have high
amounts of wealth will get high amounts of passive
income from the wealth that they own now on this
channel we have never once supported higher taxes
on working people this channel has always been
about higher taxes on people with huge amounts of
accumulated hoarded wealth if you don't tax them
they will use their enormous amounts of income to
buy the rest of the wealth, wealth inequality will
get higher and higher we will lose our middle
class and we will fall into poverty we need to
tax hoarded accumulated wealth and if we did that
it would actually enable us to potentially lower
taxes on working people now how does this relate
oh I should probably just add we're not even
necessarily advocating increasing taxes in general
really this is about changing who pays taxes at
the moment we have a system where if you come
from an ordinary background and you get a great
job and you make a lot of money you pay a ton of
tax whereas The Duke of Westminster inherited
10 billion pounds and paid nothing, so at the
moment hard-working people are paying too much tax
super-rich are not paying enough so it's not about
raising taxes on workers it's about raising taxes
on the very very rich, now how does this relate to
the question of 'if you tax the rich they'll leave'
now the reason this is related is because a lot
of people when I say raise tax on the rich they
assume I mean raise taxes on high earning working
people now if you are a high earning working
person and I raise the taxes on your work you can
leave and you can work in another country and then
the UK will not get any of your income but I'm not
advocating that I'm advocating lowering tax on
working people and raising taxes on the super rich
now why is that more effective? people sayoh but
the super rich are super mobile they are the most
mobile people they can leave, the reason that
the super rich are rich is because they own wealth
what is wealth? wealth is your house wealth, is your
mortgage, wealth is the office block that you work in
wealth is the Tesco down the street, wealth isBoots
in your high street, wealth is the shopping centre right
wealth is the farmland in the country okaythese
guys are rich because they own your mortgage
when you pay your mortgage it goes to them, they
can leave the country, it doesn't matter! because
the money comes from you, what they need is for
youto leave the country right a working person they
are rich because they work, a wealthy person he is
rich because you work, he gets his money from you
how do you think Rishi Sunak gets 30 million
pounds a year passive income without working
those payments come from you that are your
mortgage payments they are your rent payments
they are the money that you pay in profits to
corporations his money comes from you so actually
the rich are the least mobile people on Earth
because their money comes from you what they
need is for you to leave so let's say these super
rich people they leave and they own your mortgage
or we can still tax it because the money comes
from you and you are still here these people are
actually the least mobile people on earth and the
best example we have of that was Roman Abramovich
he is rich not because he works he is rich because
he owns, what he owned was Chelsea Football Club
and Chelsea Football Club is in f***in Chelsea
He can't f***in take it with him, so this idea
that if you tax them they'll leave is based
on an intentional obfuscation and confusion
of wealthy people who are ordinary people with
high-paying jobs and super super wealthy people
with hundreds of millions of pounds of assets
these people are not the same working people
can leave because they get their money from
their work rich people can leave but they get
their money from your work so we can tax their
income wherever they are because their income
comes from you so this idea that 'you can't
taxrich people, they'll leave' it's absurd and
it's obviously put about by rich people who pay
tons of money to the IEA to send ideas like this
rich people are the least mobile people in theworld
financially because what they own is fixedassets
fixed assets; your mortgage, your house,
your office building, your shopping centre
they can leave we can still tax them and if we
don'ttax them it's a political choice made by
in our country one of the richest men in the world
we can tax them and we have to if we don't
we'll all pay the price! thanks, support
the channel, follow us, share the video
housing could be so much more affordable wages
could be so much higher and we could have so
many more options in how we live our lives
someof them put a lot of money into paying
economists & thinktanks to tell you that inequality
is important for the economy that is not true
[Music]